to show you how it approached something
like this right this is I think this is
one B I think right all I'm thinking
about is this function from here to here
that's my from here to here right now
just the quickest way probably is to say
it's easier you don't remember you're
confusing your formula but it's okay now
just be careful because you know how
every formula uses H for different
things and a and B for different things
so here what is the height of my
trapezium oh yes this is the tr4 isn't
it right so we're gonna go for over to
what a and B they are the parallel signs
which are I'm gonna do the one at time
oh oh oh that's right four and eight
right so that's two times 12 which is
you're gonna get given shape it looks
like this isn't named that function it's
a whole bunch of different things but
you just need to consider the areas
areas that's what this is about okay
however this whole topic would stay
rather plain if all we did was shape so
that you already know how to find the
areas of right we could do a lot more
with this process of integration right
so I'm gonna try and show you the
insight that was developed it just blew
the door open on this
okay now I'm deliberately going to
choose a very very simple example so you
can follow the math so you don't get
lost but we're not gonna do some fairly
hard beat you okay so hold on to your
hands draw this up for me
this is a travel road okay now some of
you see travel graphs before some of you
a lot it simply tracks excuse me
the motion of an objective time okay
like where is it at a given time the
reason why I'm the appealing to this is
because the idea of gradient right
gradient being rise over run which we
write in fancy notation is dy or DX
changing Y that's rise change in X
that's run this gradient relationship is
exactly analogous
to something that a travel breath tells
us about namely in terms of things
moving around great here is how
something is changing you regard to
something else which is exactly what
speed is right what is speed comparing
but to change of two different things
distance of time excuse me so for
instance if I travel for five hours and
I pass you know 80 12 minutes in
distance they dive excuse me my speed
will be 80 over five which is 16
kilometers now right
so the speed equals distance on time now
I'm going to take this idea and we're
gonna try to squeeze some insights out
of it okay
now have a look at this travel graph
with me what I want you to consider is
we start at at time zero right he starts
at this object starts some distance away
from the origin right wherever that is
okay you guys I made some RJ after one
hour it's 80 kilometers so 80 meters or
whatever you do like 80 away from the
origin and after three hours it's a
hundred and thirty units kilometres
actually we're just going plumbers and
hours away from the origin
okay now how would I work out the speed
of this object the constant state I
would say that the speed is well between
the first hour and the third hour how
far is it travel ends up 59 very
importantly I'm gonna write down the 50
doesn't just come from 50 it comes from
130 take away 8 it comes from that
difference there right where I started
where I ended I compare those two I take
the difference and that's what gives me
the total distance I'm going to divide
that by what was the total amount of
time that I was traveling movement to
accommodate and the answer is to and
where does the to come from answer 3
take away 1 right so it's this quantity
here 3 take away what that gives you 50
over 2 which is 25 and I suppose I could
call that km/h okay that's a speed that
I'm interested now I would take this
idea of speed right if I could speak
because
is a constant travel graph is traveling
at constant speed it's not very
difficult to draw rather than a graphic
test distance against time I could
conspire compare speed to time
okay so just really quickly underneath
here it's up yes okay I can draw I
control rather than aim time sorry time
distance crap right I can draw a time
see graph okay now the speed is always
25 Club is brown so it happens to be a
very very boring graph looks like this
yes interesting right
okay now do you see if wouldn't they
want to get across to you actually very
important in 150 this is time distance
and this is time speed now remember I
was trying to say speed is just that how
you're changing which is exactly what
greatness tells you right so I could
call this for instance if this is my
original function then this is the
gradient function right so I would call
that F - are you okay with that
so distance the function speed the
gradient function right the derivative
and both of these are X's now I've drawn
them that's why I've draw them
vertically opposed to each other just
the same way that you can draw of F and
then compare it to F - okay no big deal
now here's where we're going to push on
this a trends resubmit sayin if speed
equals distance on time then it doesn't
take that much imagination to try and
solve this in reverse order and say
what's distance equal to in terms of the
other 215 Lutz's you just multiply time
across right so I would say speed times
time does that make sense so for
instance if I were to solve this
particular question but solve it in
Reverse right I could say well let's
come down to this graph TR and from one
is going to go to
there and three is gonna go to about
there so this here what am i solving for
this particular set of numbers here
I had a distance of fifty that distance
there over a time of 2 hours do you hear
is math so what I had was distance was
50 right speed was 25 and I was
traveling for two hours now he's the
crucial insight okay we know what this
means
on this crap it's up great what does
this mean
on this graph the answer is this
statement here should look familiar
shouldn't it right back to the beginning
of this lesson I drew this thing I said
that multiplication is really about well
it's used to understand area right area
50 equals 25 times 2 this is an area
isn't it what area is it it's the area
of this guide here it's the area under
this particular curve do you see that
this area under the curve is what this
tells me okay
now I knew all of the numbers here I
knew exactly what was happening here and
therefore I could draw some conclusions
off of this right but what this is
suggesting is that like how do I go from
here to here answer by differentiated
that's how it's what's what speed is
right a different shade going down here
in order to work out the area from this
right all these note from here is now
stop stop stop what is on this team is
I'm a three note C which was the actual
area 50 that is the actual area where
does 50 appear on this graph
answer yeah and this is why I
highlighted this right it's the total
distance covered right it's the start
point and the end point compared right
that distance there this is the area
down here so what's going on here right
I've chosen a simple example I chose a
straight line okay
it wasn't even inclined off like that
that's why I just got a simple
rectangular plane but if I want to work
out the area under the curve all I need
to work out is having gone backwards for
differentiating which we gave this name
we called it anti-differentiate right
from here to here all I need to know is
a start and end point a start and an end
point okay
now remembering that you go from F to F
Dash is different shipping right I can
just rename these things right if I call
this the actual function I'm interested
in let's call this F right then the
function I came from the differentiates
down to this guy is the primitive I call
you in capital F right so if I start
with this and I want to know this area
under the curve if I can know about the
thing that was a differentiated to get
to to climb up the ladder all I needed
this is these two dollars okay so
therefore how would I state by the way
space this area under the cap like I
need numerically what it is but in
integral language which is all about
areas under cups how would I state it
number one it's not the integral sign
what might down from 1/3 now the thing I
get ready is this guy right f of X and
I'm doing that with respect to X this is
little bits now what is it actually
equal to right well I needed the stop
point I need the end point really its
end takeaway stop does that make sense
now when Meghan 1831 30 from they came
from these values one in three right do
you agree that if this is one then 80 is
F of 1/2 beer that like that's the
vertical part and this guy is F of 3 so
to get that 58 hours after the 50 which
is the actual answer I just have to do F
of 3 and take away F of 1 I just need
the stein endpoints of the primitive
that will tell me the area of the actual
function I'm interested ok